luis castillo makes his way from the
reds first base side dugout tonight
playing in his
265th consecutive game the longest
active streak in major league baseball
and he has gone on three pitches to
start the game
20 40 home marks and what a start by
castillo back-to-back strikeouts against
these two right-handed batters and here
comes yet another and perez well this is
definitely the change-up right here and
it goes down and in and boy you know
what really set that up though was that
luis castillo was just painting the
outside corner with the first two
strikes castionis hitting 293.
nice play by monday and he turns around
for some extra leverage and throws out
castellanos and they weren't quite
positioned right but when you have range
one hopper like that a lot of shortstops
aren't getting to that it's all about
first step quickness he'd not tapped his
glove once but twice for rhythm and bang
bang just got him in first base and and
he's more sure and more confident booby
says thank you that was a big lift
see if the reds can deliver a two-out
knock from farmer three and two runners
get started
and a high fly ball right center field
and that's up against the wall
two runs are gonna score and kyle's
farmer with a big two out two run double
to give cincinnati a two-nothing lead
how about kyle farmer probably had an
excellent bat because he worked to count
full and then boobage had to come in
there with something i think it was a
change-up that he threw right there was
but he got a way up in the zone farmers
a good high ball hitter the reds out to
a two-nothing loser
he grounded out to short his first time
up
[Applause]
the infield was playing back and that
hopped up on suarez he tried to swipe at
it and he missed and salvi will be on to
put runners at first and second with one
out so the royals come back with two
base runners and now hunter dozier he's
singled on a first pitch in the second
inning
ground ball to the right side but
bobbled by the first baseman
and now everybody's going to be
safe for the royals they have the bases
loaded joey vado who is usually a
terrific first baseman booted the ball
and he's mad at himself yelling the
royals had a chance last inning
somebody's got to come through for swing
and a drive to the left field and that's
deep that's a way back and it's off the
wall
and comes one
and comes salvador perez no they'll hold
salvi at third base so the royals do
score a run and pull within two to one
and they still have just one out so
o'hearn comes through again good stroke
way to go be productive that's all you
can do hit it hard somewhere now another
tough hitter and matt davidson walked
his first time level this one a deep
right center field and davidson plays
long ball to right center all of a
sudden matt davidson coming up big for
the red legs
a two out two run home run
to make it a four to one game i wasn't
sure when that ball came off the bat but
he had a chance to even get to the
warning trap and he was so strong
and that ball just kept going and going
and a change up again got plenty enough
for the meat part of the bat club's a
two out two two-run home run and a
three-run lead for the reds maker has
singled his first time up behind hero
and two
this ball driven hard
in a deep left center field and that's
out of here by jesse winker back to back
for the red legs with two outs here in
the third against boobage
and by the rockets red glare it is a 5-1
cincinnati lead winker is white hot all
right so now with mirrorfield for
already the third time in this game he
has struck out and lined out hard to
center
off the end of the bat this time and
coming up is senzelle and he tried to
grab it with his bare hand
the royals will get a run out of that as
lopez comes around to score
and it's 5-2 as whit drives in lopez
with one out a lot easier when you use
your glove
solaire
one hopper farmer for one cologne turns
it over
so after some sloppy defense in the last
two innings the inning ends with a
sparkling play and the reds are able to
turn it into an inning
double play
monday hits it hard to the right side
and cologne
and it's off of vato's glove salvador
perez scores and we'll see how they
score it but it looked like another play
that should have been an out and it's
5-3 in the fifth inning
to see as a base runner one or goes
through down to second base not going to
be in time are they asking for a review
of this
oh
he did his spikes lifted off the back
the only thing chris i wonder is is
because you make the argument that his
first swipe tag knocked monday off the
bag you can't knock a guy off the base
correct well obviously they're taking a
long look at it from multiple angles and
they're saying out as a call wow how
about that the royals get one the reds
still eat it it's now the reds five
royal three three balls and a strike to
ryan o'hearn
and a liner up the middle oh my farmer
he gets one farmer against two he's been
the player of the night
he has been the reds player of the night
by far and away not even close what a
play by kyle farmer as he saves the reds
and the reds will lead this one five
mcbroom is going to bat for alex gordon
he's going to pull it
deep to left field and ryan mcbroom
comes off the bench
and ties it with a two run
pinch hit home run man oh man that's
what you look for for from a pinch
hitter it was a no doubter and boom goes
big boom whales continue to run out
their bullpen which has just been
nothing shy of spectacular
here tonight uh josh
starmont and all the chips are down here
in the last of the tenth senzelle and
castianos at second and first
[Applause]
in the air straight away center field
senzel should tag on this unless it
leaves a yard and it's against the wall
and the reds are going to win the game
on a base hit by joey vado senzel scores
the first walk-off win of the year for
the cincinnati reds
cashes in here in the bottom of the 10th
inning wasted no time at all on the very
first pitch he saw and almost left the
yard
so joey vito makes reds history